we're going to begin at a very critical
moment for president biden today in his
ambitious agenda overnight the house
passed a bill to prevent a government
shutdown for now but it received no
republican support at all the bill now
goes to the senate where it could fail
this comes after president biden's
speech at the u.n seeking to reassure
our allies that the u.s is committed to
global leadership on the pandemic and
other issues wishing is at the white
house with some breaking news for us
this morning wija good morning to you
what can you tell us
good morning to you gail and good
morning to everybody well today
president biden plans to announce that
the u.s will purchase more than 1
billion doses of the pfizer vaccine to
share with lower income countries that
is more than double the original
purchase plan as he supports the goal to
get 70 percent of the world vaccinated
within a year it's also part of
president biden's promise to lead global
progress as a trusted partner but in
recent weeks some u.s allies have
questioned american credibility forcing
the president to defend some pieces of
his foreign policy all while his
domestic policy goals are in jeopardy
during his first address to the united
nations general assembly on tuesday
president biden called for closer
international cooperation to tackle
everything from the covet 19 pandemic to
human rights abuses let's make our
better future now
but ties with some u.s allies are
strained in part because of how the
president withdrew u.s forces from
afghanistan he framed the end of the war
as a chance to reset relationships as we
close this period of relentless war
we're opening a new era of relentless
diplomacy and from foreign policy to the
domestic agenda mr biden tied the
climate change crisis to his 3.5
trillion dollar infrastructure bill but
that legislation and a smaller
bipartisan measure aimed at repairing
roads and bridges is in jeopardy because
of rifts in the president's own party
more than half our members will not move
the bipartisan bill without the
reconciliation bill being passed
republicans say the democrats proposal
is one reason why they won't support
raising the debt ceiling the reckless
taxing and spending spree
that washington democrats are assembling
behind closed doors
would put more debt
more borrowing
and more inflation on the shoulders of
american families the bill is passed
overnight the house passed a measure to
raise the debt ceiling and avoid a
government shutdown at the end of the
month extending funding through december
3rd but it will be much tougher to clear
the senate a government shutdown would
be a very bad thing for our country
if the u.s defaults on its debt
economists warn that would have a
devastating impact on jobs and the stock
market later today president biden plans
to host democratic leaders and house
lawmakers here to talk about that and to
round up more support for his
infrastructure agenda tony
weisha thank you very much and